ثلاث دول فقط ستؤخذ ترشيحاتها في الاعتبار
لاستضافه اكسبو 2020
السعوديه التي رشحت الرياض وكوريا
الجنوبيه التي رشحت بوسان وايطاليا التي
رشحت روما اختيرت هذه الدول عبر التصويت
كما اوضح المكتب الدولي للمعارض مشيرا الى
انها قدمت مقترحات قابله للتطبيق وتحترم
المعايير المطلوبه تعاقب المسؤولون
السعوديون على الكلام مجمعين على ان
المملكه جاهزه لاستضافه اكسبو 2020
السعوديه تتموضع بشكل فريد كجسر يربط بين
الشمال والجنوب وبين الشرق والغرب والرياض
مدينه عالميه تنبض بالحياه من بين
المعايير التي قبلت الترشيحات على اساسها
جاذبيه شعار الترشح وهو بالنسبه للرياض
مثلا مع ان نستشرف المستقبل والمعايير
الاخرى تمحور ت حول الدعم المحلي والوطني
بالترشح في الدوله المعنيه والامكانيات
الماليه المرصوده وحجم المشاركه المتوقعه
يندرج ضمن رؤيه 2030 هدف وصول استثماراتنا
الى 3.3 تريليون دولار مع نهايه هذا العقد
وسيخصص لاكسب الرياض مبلغ 7 مليارات و800
مليون دولار
رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه يون سوكيول حضر شخصيا
لدعم ترشح مدينه بوسان
بوسان هي بوابه النحو قارتي اوروبا واسيا
سيكون اكسبو 2020 مناسبه لها لخلق فرص عمل
جديده التصويت النهائي لاختيار المدينه
التي ستستضيف اكسبو 2020
سيجري في نوفمبر من هذا العام بالاقتراع
السري قال المكتب الدولي للمعارض ان ملفات
الترشيح الثلاثه التي
اعتبار تتضمن
مقتراه
فيما اكد وفد المملكه جهزيه العاصمه
السعوديه لاستضافه افضل نسخه من الاكسبو
على الاطلاق عبر تاريخه حسين قنيبر
العربيه باريس لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات